Swiss engineering has a reputation for
being precise and reliable and
Switzerland has a reputation of being
not paranoid exactly but at least taking
a lot of precautions about their safety
Switzerland is the only country in the
world with enough nuclear fallout
shelters for the entire population even
now it's a legal requirement that any
new build house here must have a shelter
if it's not close enough to an existing
one and okay a lot of those shelters are
being used mostly to storage these days
probably for cheese but if the world
takes a dark path Switzerland is ready
and that extends to this the drinking
water I'm in Zurich the largest city in
Switzerland and it has an entire backup
water supply system the city has
hundreds of drinking fountains free for
public use of all sorts of designs and
okay most of them are fed from the same
pipes as homes and offices it's mostly
filtered water from nearby legs Yorick
with a bit of spring water and
groundwater mixed in it is of course
some of the safest drinking water in the
world because Switzerland but in the
event of an emergency let's say the lake
was contaminated somehow or there's a
day's long power cut that shuts all the
pumps down not that that's likely
because the electricity supplies just to
secure but if it happens
Zurich is still prepared there is an
entire backup water system fed by
nothing more than gravity from a spring
on a nearby mountain it runs through 150
kilometres of pipes two taps in
hospitals and fallout shelters and
special drinking fountains like this
these can all be adapted so they can
fill a lot of buckets in a very short
amount of time with nothing more than
some hoses and scaffolding this water
isn't being wasted by the way I mean it
is no one's drinking it but if it wasn't
going through these pipes
it would just be joining a river and
heading straight to the ocean by a
different path lots of cities maintain
some level of redundant water supply
some backup pipes or emergency tankers
in case everything fails but Zurich they
have two systems constantly tested
always running together just in case the
world ends